all right so um yes thank you to the
organizers for inviting me I had this
ESS I'm going to be talking about
identifiability a viscoelastic
mechanical systems and this is joint
work with Adam audience at sullivant so
so I'm gonna be talking about structural
identifiability today so structural
identifiability is about finding which
unknown parameters of a model can be
determined from known input output data
so we use the word structural here which
basically means we're assuming we have
perfect data in other words it's noise
free and it's of any time duration
required so this is as opposed to what's
often called numerical or practical
identifiability which is actually the
parameter estimation problem when you
have real and often noisy data so why do
we care about structural identifiability
well structural identifiability is a
necessary condition for practical
identifiability and as we'll see shortly
it's just going to be an algebraic
condition so the reason I'm talking
about it today is it's going to boil
down to just solving a system of
polynomial equations all right so where
does it come up well it comes up in
biological modeling so for example in
systems biology in biochemical reaction
networks but today I'm going to be
talking about what are called
viscoelastic mechanical models so a
outline for my talk today is I'm first
going to give some background on what it
means to be a viscoelastic mechanical
model then I'll talk about the
identifiability problem and finally I'll
talk about some of our results okay so
first let's talk about what it means to
be elastic so an elastic material can be
represented by a spring and a spring
obeys Hookes law this relationship will
actually Hookes law divided by the area
but we get this relationship sigma
equals e times epsilon where Sigma is
the stress epsilon is the strain and E
is our spring constant so this is
typically an unknown parameter but the
idea is if you knew your stress and you
and you knew your strain at some time
instance you could plug that information
into this equation and you could
determine your spring constant okay so
now let's talk about what it means to be
a viscous material so a viscous material
can be represented by what's called a
dashpot or more familiarly by a piston
like in your car and a dashpot obeys
this relationship sigma equals 8 times
epsilon dot where epsilon dot is the
derivative of the strain and ADA is your
dashpot constant again it's typically an
unknown parameter but again if you knew
your stress and you knew your strain
rate at some time instance you could
plug that in and determine the dashpot
constant okay so now let's talk about
what it means to be a viscoelastic
material so that means your property or
material exhibits both viscous and
elastic properties so the way we
represent this is by combining Springs
and dash pots in series or in parallel
so for example we could do a simple
series extension we could do a parallel
extension or we could do something more
complicated by continuing to combine in
series or in parallel so we call this a
spring dashpot network all right so
where are these used well one particular
application is in cardiovascular
modeling so in our body's changing blood
pressure causes periodic expansion and
contraction of the arterial walls in
other words the walls of our arteries
and if you look at the stress-strain
curves of the arterial walls they
exhibit hysteresis which basically means
instead of just having a nice simple
linear relationship between the stress
and the strain which would be signature
of a elastic material you have a more
complicated relationship which means
that it's viscous and elastic so for
this reason we can use spring dashpot
networks to model the biomechanical
properties of the arterial walls
okay so let's say so let's say we have
some spring dashpot network so the idea
is for each individual spring and
dashpot they have their own
corresponding spring and dashpot
constant so for example in this picture
here we have four springs and four dash
pots so that means we have a total of
eight different constants which means we
really have eight different
stress-strain relationships so what we
would like to do is find a relationship
between the total stress and the total
strain in other words what we'd really
like to do is do some elimination and
get a single equation purely in terms of
the total stress in the total strength
okay so the way we're going to do this
is using sort of two very fundamental
physics rules the first is if you
combine in series the stress is the same
on both elements but the total strain is
the sum of the individual strains versus
if you combine in parallel the strain is
the same on both elements but then the
total stress is the sum of the
individual stresses okay so let's look
at an example okay so let's say I decide
to take a spring in a dashpot and
combine them in series so this is a
commonly done so it has a special name
it's called a maxwell element so for our
spring and for our dash pot we have
these two stress-strain relationships
and what we would do is use these rules
we just mentioned the stresses are the
same but the total strains for the total
strains that you some the individual
strains so what we can do is take our
two equations divided by their
respective constants sum them up and
then we can eliminate the individual
stresses and strains and get this total
stress strain relationship so here we
can see it's this first order linear
differential equation okay so now let's
say we decide to combine in parallel so
we take our spring we take our dashpot
we combine them in parallel now the
strains are the same but the stresses
are added so again we could take our
equations sum them up and then we can
eliminate the individual stresses and
strains using our rules and again get a
total stress strain relationship in this
case again we get a first order linear
differential equation okay so you can
imagine continuing this type of process
so let's say for example we take a voice
and we take a Maxwell put them in series
this is called a burgers model and again
the idea is you can use these rules to
eliminate the individual stresses and
strains and get a total stress strain
relationship so in this case we get this
second order linear differential
equation so as we're seeing sort of the
pattern is we always get these linear
differential equations where the
coefficients are rational functions in
the parameters and the unknown
parameters okay alright so let's
generalize so first of all we found that
for any configuration of n Springs and M
dash pots you can always get a total
stress strain relationship of one of
four types and the types are defined by
the differential orders the highest
differential orders and the lowest
differential orders in in Sigma and an
epsilon so in the first type type a as
you can see we have the highest
differential order in epsilon is equal
to the highest differential order in
Sigma we're calling that n and likewise
for the lowest differential orders
they're both 0 a differential order to
the lowest differential order okay and a
spring falls into that category so then
for type be the highest differential
order in epsilon is one greater than
that in Sigma and likewise for the
lowest differential order it's one
greater than that for Sigma and a
dashpot falls into that category then we
have type C again similar relationship
in this case the highest differential
order in epsilon is again one greater
than the highest differential order in
Sigma and then the lowest differential
orders are the same they're both 0 and
avoid avoid element follows that pattern
and finally we have type
d where the highest differential orders
are the same but the lowest differential
order in epsilon is one greater than in
Sigma and a Maxwell follows that pattern
okay so the idea is we have this total
stress strain relationship so now we can
go ahead and talk about the
identifiability problem so in the
classic identifiability problem set up
the idea is we assume we can recover
values of our coefficients of our total
stress strain relationship from enough
known input output data in other words
in our case stress and strain data so
the question is is it possible to
recover values of the parameters from
these coefficients so in other words
looking back at our example this burgers
model the idea is we're assuming we know
values of the four coefficients in red
but the question is can we determine the
individual parameters in this case
there's four of them eem EV a2m and a
tavi okay so of course another way of
saying this is if we form the mapping
from our four parameters to these four
coefficients what we're really asking is
is this mapping one to one says my
mapping for my four parameters to these
four coefficients is that one to one
okay so let's formalize this so we have
some total stress strain relationship
and I've just listed one of the types
here and I should mention that we when
we talk about identifiability we always
want to normalize the equation so we
either have it monic in epsilon or in
sigma and we can form our coefficient
map which is a mapping from our n plus M
parameters because there was n Springs
and M dash pots to our coefficients and
by number of coefficients here I really
mean the number of non monic
coefficients in other words all the
coefficients besides the coefficient one
so we can form this coefficient mapping
and we define identifiability in the
following way we say our model is
globally identifiable if and only if our
efficient map see is one to one locally
identify a bowl if and only if it's
finite 21 and unidentifiable if and only
if its infinite 21 and I should mention
here an important point is we're going
to be considering generic
identifiability in other words the
identifiability holds everywhere except
on a set of measure zero so even though
I may sometimes forget to say that we
are always talking about generic
identifiability all right okay so i'll
go ahead and state our main result so we
found that a viscoelastic mechanical
model hat is locally identifiable if and
only if the number of coefficients in
other words the number of non monica
coefficients equals the number of
parameters and i'm going to spend
basically the rest of the talk giving
sort of an outline for this for the
proof of this theorem but I want to
mention the forward Direction is
actually not too hard to see we found
that for viscoelastic mechanical models
the number of parameters is always
greater than or equal to the number of
coefficients so from this we can get
that a necessary condition for local
identifiability is that the number of
coefficients equal the number of
parameters so showing that it's a
sufficient condition as well as a bit
trickier and that's what I'll spend most
of the time describing so how would we
use this result well going back to our
three examples of the voids and maxwell
and burgers models you can see all we
have to do is just count the number of
coefficients and count the number of
parameters and see that they're equal so
all three of these models are in fact at
least locally identifiable i'll talk
about they're actually globally
identifiable and i'll talk about that
later in the talk okay so how are we
going to prove this result well the idea
is let's consider a spring dashpot
system m which is a series connection of
two systems n1 and n2 and I should
mention in a everything i'm going to say
even though i'm gonna be talking about
the series connection everything can be
analogously applied for a parallel
connection so I'm going to focus on a
series connection all right so we found
that a necessary condition for em to be
locally identifiable is that both the
systems n1 and n2 are both locally
identifiable and to be more specific we
found that the coefficient maps for
these systems n1 and n2 have to be
generically finite to one and also on to
so this will come into this will be
important later on okay so what this
means then is if we have some system m
and we want to determine if it's locally
identifiable we can reduce this problem
to just asking the following question
when is the series connection of to
locally identifiable models locally
identifiable okay so before i get into
answering that i want to mention one
other result we have and this result is
sort of a combination of our result
about the types and our results about
identifiability so we found that let's
say you have to locally identifiable
systems n1 and n2 and is let's say you
combine them in series we found that the
resulting model is either identifiable
of one of these four types a B C or D or
it's unidentifiable which we denote by
you so in other words this table shows
if shows us if I take any two systems of
let's say for example a Type A and a
Type B let's say and I combine them in
series this the fact that i have a d
here means that that resulting model is
type d and it's identifiable and we have
a similar table for the parallel case
okay so how would we use this result
well the idea is we can actually
determine local identifiability without
even calculating the total stress strain
relationship so what this means is if I
have some complicated stress oh sorry a
spring dashpot network since the spring
is type a and a dashpot is tight V I can
describe it in terms of the series and
parallel connection
use my tables and successively simplify
this down to in this case a type D so
this model is in fact locally
identifiable all right okay so let's get
back to this question of trying to prove
our main result so the way we're going
to do this is the following we're going
to generalize the process of combining
in series and in parallel using this
linear differential operator notation so
let's say I have to spring dashpot
networks and 1 and n 2 that are both
locally identifiable i'm going to
rewrite the stress-strain relationship
slightly will write them in terms of
these linear differential operators
where for example will write l1 having
its highest differential order is n1 and
its lowest differential order is m 1 and
similarly for the other operators and we
saw earlier that there's actually
restrictions on the highest differential
orders and lowest differential orders
but for now let's just write things in
this general form just for simplicity
okay so now let's talk about a series
connection so we said when we combine in
series the stresses are the same but the
strains are added so what we can do if
you sort of think of these manipulating
these linear differential operators kind
of like polynomials since they're really
just like polynomials and DDT we can
multiply the first equation by L 3
multiply the second equation by L 1 and
then some these two equations and then
we can eliminate the individual stresses
and strains and thus get this total
stress strain relationship and I should
mention so in order to make sure in
order to guarantee that this equation is
monic what we would do for a series
connection is we would want l1 and l3 to
be monic so that this resulting equation
is monic in since l1 x l3 would then be
monic okay so now for a parallel
connection in this case the strains are
the same but the stresses are added so
in this case we could multiply the first
equation by L for the second equation by
l2 again sum them up
and we get our total stress strain
relationship and again to guarantee that
it's monic we would want L to to be l2
and l for to be monic so that the
resulting equation is monic okay so we
had mentioned earlier that there was
only specific types of viscoelastic
models and now what we're going to do is
rephrase that result in terms of what
we're going to call the shape of a
linear operator so we'll define the
shape of a linear operator as a pair of
numbers ni and mi where ni is the
highest differential order and mi is the
lowest differential order so we could
just rephrase our previous result in
terms of shapes so for example type a
the shape of the linear operator in
epsilon would be n 0 and the linear
operator acting on Sigma would be m0 etc
okay so what we're going to do why are
we talking about shapes well the idea is
we can totally rephrase our
identifiability problem in terms of what
we're going to call a shape
factorization problem so again let's let
n 1 and n 2 BR locally identifiable
networks that have these stress-strain
relationships so let's say I take my two
networks and I combine them in series so
what does that mean well one way of
thinking about that is we're taking our
equations for n1 and n2 and mapping them
to this new equation f epsilon equals G
Sigma where F is l1 times l3 and g is a
1 times L 4 plus L 2 times L 3 alright
so what does this mean in terms of
identifiability well what we can think
of this as is it's the way to check
identifiability is really what we're
asking is is the mapping from our old
coefficients to these new coefficients
is that finite to one in other words if
you think of your coefficients of your
two networks of it of the two
stress-strain relationships for n1 n2 as
arbitrary in other words they're kind of
like your parameters you're really
asking is that step finite to one ok so
what we're going to do is because the
shapes of l1 l2 l3 and l4 all
of they all their shapes are all
determined by these specific networks n1
and n2 we can rephrase the
identifiability problem in terms of
their shapes so let me go ahead and
define the problem so we say the shape
factorization problem for some quadruple
of shapes is for a generic politics for
a generic pair of polynomials F and G
where F is monic and the shape of F and
the shape of G are given by these
expressions here the question is does
there exist finitely many quadruples of
polynomials l1 l2 l3 l4 where the shape
of Li is ni mi and l1 and l3 are monic
such that F equals a1 times l3 and G
equals a1 times all four plus L 2 times
l three ok so let's demonstrate this
with an example so let's say we're
combining a type a and a type C in
series so for example let's just pick a
quadruple of this form 2020 for a and 30
20 for see so let's let F and G be a
generic pair of polynomials that are
both degree 5 with nonzero constant
terms and f is monic then our question
is does there exist finitely many
polynomials l1 l2 l3 and l4 such that F
equals a1 times l3 and G equals a1 times
L 4 plus L 2 times l three so
equivalently obviously another way of
saying this is for generic values of our
coefficients of F and our coefficients
of G does this system in 11 of 11
equations in 11 unknowns have only
finitely many solutions right ok so
let's talk about solving this problem so
the key idea here is that forgiven
shapes n 1 m 1 and n 3 m3 there are most
finitely many ways to factor a monic
polynomial into monic factors where L 1
has she
and 1 m 1 and similarly for l 3 so once
we pick one of these finitely many
factorizations that means we fix l1 and
fix l3 then this equation for G is now a
linear system in the unknowns l2 and l 4
so now that it's a linear system we just
want to know when does this linear
system have a unique solution and we
found that it has one solution if and
only if the number of coefficients
equals the number of parameters so the
way we determine this was when you form
this linear system and when you look at
your matrix it turns out that a sub
matrix of your matrix is actually the
sylvester matrix of l1 and l3 and since
the sylvester matrix is invertible for
generic polynomials l1 and l3 then we
found that our matrix is generically
invertible if and only if then it's a
square matrix and we found that happens
precisely when number of coefficients
equals number of parameters all right so
then let's talk about this question of
global identifiability so this is
basically the question as of when do we
have a unique solution to our shape
factorization problem and this happens
when f has a unique factorization well
when does that happen that happens
precisely when the highest differential
order equals the lowest differential
order in either l1 or l3 in other words
you just have a single term and that
happens only when you're adding either a
spring or a dashpot exactly one at a
time so for example going back to this
model here we found that it was locally
identifiable but it's also globally
identifiable because each spring in each
dashpot each time we're adding them
we're adding them precisely one at a
time so what's an example of something
that's locally but not globally
identifiable for example if you took
avoid this spring and dash pod in
parallel and then combined it with
another void in series though that would
be locally but not globally because you
could sort of generically exchange them
okay so I guess I'll and they're so in
summary we found necessary and
sufficient conditions for global and
local identifiability we found these
tables and I just want to very briefly
mention everything we talked about today
in terms of viscoelastic models can be
exactly translated to the electric
circuit world with resistors and
capacitors so if for the equations for
resistors and capacitors you could get
in terms of voltage and current exactly
translates the problem is though if you
add a third element and inductor then
things get a bit trickier so that's what
we're working on now all right that's it
thank you okay you seem to be assuming
that all the circuits are serious peril
sure yeah so that's that's the only one
we didn't we didn't do like kerckhoff
loop rules or anything like that we only
did the simple series and parallel
connections there was for all
constructible networks by a series of in
parallel yes
question I mean that's a big big
literature in the natural engineering
side of network realization passive
Network conversation analysis stuff
relate to or to all of that so you mean
in terms of identifiability well so so
yeah so I mean so actually the
identifiability problem interestingly
enough isn't really studied very very I
mean it's not actually very it hadn't
been studied very very much up to this
point so we actually there wasn't you
know there wasn't sort of a standard
method so that's why you know we were
able to sort of apply these this more
unique legislation somehow if you can
exactly identify the parameters well
yeah so that it was about that
coefficient map when we form our total
stress strain relationship about
determining if that coefficient map was
you know generically one-to-one finite
to honor and or infinite one but also in
engineering oftentimes you have
nonlinear problems so you I mean we only
touch the linear version of viscoelastic
so this was sort of an you know ideal
case
the question
no okay so when they're up here